the question of your success or failure
in a job interview is to a large extent
out of your hands that's what's wrong
with job interviews right the reason we
want to fix job interview is we want to
make it possible for success or failure
to be in the hands of the interviewee
that a zip is an honest we want to make
it into an honest attempt to judge your
abilities and your ability to kind of
rise to the occasion but the problem now
with the job interviews you don't know
what they want right that the whole
process of selection is hidden behind
all these unconscious doors and subject
to so many hidden implicit biases so
it's a kind of there isn't really good
news apart from smile and look good and
have a firm handshake and play by these
incredibly dumb rules that govern too
much of the interview process
when you don't do a kind of formal
interviewing process what you're doing
is you are surrendering to the
idiosyncrasies of the interviewer so
whatever it is the interviewer wants on
a conscious or an unconscious level is
going to be the criteria that matters
right so you know if you are so it's of
matching yourself to the kind of
unconscious requirements of your
interviewer is really important and you
know those people who are there are
people who are very good at kind of your
great salesmen are great at that game at
understanding what is that you are
looking for in another person right what
are you looking for in a car salesman do
you want the fast talker do you want the
reassuring uncle figure do you want the
kind of very in the distant in the
background kind of shy kind of I mean
what do you want to be bossed around or
do you want to be counted too I mean
these are all kinds of things that the
great I I one of my books I spend a lot
of time with great car salesman and its
really interesting me that's their best
the game they play right you walk into
the room and they immediately ask
themselves the question what kind of car
salesman do you want and I will be that
person right so that's the kind of game
that your left being forced to play in a
world where employers don't take the job
interview seriously I remember once when
I was getting my first job at the
Washington Post by my family's half West
Indian and I went into the job interview
and the woman of the recruiter for the
Washington Post was a West Indian so I
was like all right and so I talked about
West Indian literature the entire time I
mean it wasn't even a sort of cynical
thing was kind of I was like 22 years
old I didn't really know what I was
doing but on some level I understood
look I had no experience as a journalist
I was 22 I was it was a total and utter
long shot I don't business being there
my only chance was to make this person
seemed like feel like she was my best
friend so I was like you know let's play
it up for both West Indians and so and
you know what it worked I got job right
so you know that's I'm by the way that's
outrageous that's not what a job when
you're supposed to be about but you know
if they're going to if they're going to
play the game that way that's the way
that's the way you have to respond